the financial system of market-based
economics invariably has periods of
recession periods of when people have
overbought undersold or whatever and
that's going to happen again there's no
question but what just happened the last
three years is much much bigger than
most market-based slowdowns or
recessions and was based on some very
big we might call fault line problems
that have to be dealt with what I'm
concerned and I think we will by the way
but there are two things to keep in mind
this was so severe that our economic
base that we're now going to have to
build back from has contracted
dramatically it's nowhere near as large
as it was and we won't go back to an
economic base that big for at least 10
to 15 years number two I very I worry
more than anything else that we're about
to make a huge strategic mistake
economically and that is to think that
we can turn around on a dime and through
harsh taxes and harsh spending cuts
reduce our deficits and not bring on a
big second recession timing is
everything we are not ready to stop
stimulus in fact we need another
stimulus program we are not ready to
give up on spending money on
infrastructure problems that are really
an investment ret roads which are
deteriorating dramatically rails which
are way behind other big countries on
education so I hear the voices from sort
of the conservative wing in Congress
saying it's time right now to start
slashing our budgets to raise them not
to raise taxes but to cut spending very
dramatically on everything from
education to roads and bridges and I
think that's a ticket for disaster now
i'm not at spencer who says let's spend
the kind of money we're spending now
forever but we just simply have not come
out of recession enough we have not
built and sustained economic growth
again enough to begin that and when we
do begin it we should be doing it
we should try to solve the deficit
problem in one fell swoop it's going to
take 10 years to do it and we can afford
that as long as we get on the right
track but we're not going to get on the
right track if we don't first pay
attention to what needs to be done to
regenerate growth in the economy solid
growth based on real productivity and
real innovation and I just hope that
wiley's and office the Obama
administration has the grid to stick to
the job of rebuilding the economy and
our capabilities our productivity before
trying to resolve to a great extent that
the deficit problem that's later that's
not for now